et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
François-Xavier Bellamy bonjour bon
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous des
plutôt européens vice-président exécutif
des républicains en étant ça pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Stéphane Vernet de
westfrance bonjour Stéphane bonjour
bonjour la réforme des retraites est
donc désormais adoptée François-Xavier
Bellamy l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas
voté la motion de censure ça s'est joué
à neuf voit près et ton ce matin dans
une crise politique bien sûr une crise
politique majeure parce que ce que nous
voyons aujourd'hui c'est qu'en réalité
il n'y a pas de majorité réelle pour
gouverner ce pays et cette crise elle
concerne tout le paysage politique elle
concerne bien sûr le gouvernement et sa
majorité mais elle concerne aussi toutes
les oppositions et je crois qu'il est
temps de réaliser l'ampleur de la
défiance démocratique qui s'exprime dans
ce pays et moi j'en veux terriblement à
celui qui est le grand responsable de
cette situation j'en veux à Emmanuel
Macron parce que ce qu'on vit
aujourd'hui
c'est la catastrophe absolue qui résulte
du en même temps d'une politique de la
confusion permanente d'une politique qui
a tout vendu à tout le monde pour à la
fin ne rien permettre au pays de
construire comme cap politique claire en
fait cette réforme des retraites elle
est d'abord le symptôme de cette
faute originaire et le président de la
République lui-même pendant tout son
premier quinquennat avait été le
principal détracteur de la réforme qu'il
porte aujourd'hui comment est-ce que
dans cette absence totale le clarté dans
cette absence de transparence dans cette
absence de responsabilité démocratique
comment est-ce qu'on peut imaginer
produire autre chose que la crise
politique que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui vous avez aucun crise
politique majeure est-ce qu'on peut
parler de crise de régime comme font
certains insoumis c'est une crise
politique parce que au fond la chance
que nous avons aujourd'hui c'est que nos
institutions sont solides si ça n'était
pas le cas nous serions sans doute bien
loin de laquelle
gouvernement à l'avenir pourra encore
utiliser utiliser un 49-3 je crois que
le gouvernement ne peut pas espérer plus
longtemps s'appuyer sur cette solidité
de nos institutions pour pouvoir se
reposer de son absence de responsabilité
politique et je crois que c'est c'est
cette situation qui appelle aujourd'hui
un sursaut je crois que bien sûr
pour vous en tous les cas mon sentiment
c'est que si Elisabeth borne était
vraiment responsable et si par ailleurs
elle avait un peu de panache qui compte
aussi en politique je crois qu'elle
partirait parce qu'on voit très bien
aujourd'hui que le gouvernement je le
redis n'a pas de véritable majorité je
ne dis pas qu'elle le doit au sens des
institutions le 49-3 lui permet de
l'éviter mais avec 9 voies de majorité
encore une fois on ne peut pas s'appuyer
sur
de notre système constitutionnel pour
s'exonérer de sa responsabilité
politique pour vous elle doit partir
est-ce que ça changerait quelque chose
est-ce que c'est vraiment Isabelle borde
le problème
le problème c'est que cette réforme des
retraites a cristallisé à cristalliser
la défiance profonde de la société et
encore une fois je le dis en ayant
assumé depuis le début que je suis
favorable à cette réforme des retraites
comme la plupart de mes collègues
parlementaires des républicains qui ont
soutenu cette réforme parce que nous
demandons depuis très longtemps une
réforme qui permettrait enfin de
redonner aux Français un peu de
lisibilité sur l'avenir qui redonnerait
du salaire aux plus jeunes qui leur
redonnerait une assurance sur leur futur
une réforme qui permettrait aussi que la
France retrouve sa compétitivité mais il
aurait fallu la mener cette réforme en
l'ayant assumé depuis le début comme un
engagement clair ce n'était pas le cas
en l'ayant pour que les forts ne
reposent pas toujours sur les mêmes
entouré de tout ce qui est nécessaire
pour que la France se remette à
travailler mieux en ayant fait une vraie
réforme de l'éducation pour récupérer
les 150 000 jeunes qu'on perd chaque
année en ayant fait une vraie réforme de
l'assurance chômage pour que notre
système social cesse de désinciter au
travail en ayant fait une vraie réforme
de la fin des carrières pour pouvoir
faire en sorte que les carrières
pénibles soient conclu par des années
qui soient l'occasion d'un travail
différent
est-ce que si hier vous avez été au sein
de l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée nationale
la semaine dernière à ce que vous auriez
voté la réforme hier est-ce que vous
auriez voté la censure oui je le dis
très clairement j'aurais voté la réforme
et je n'aurais pas voté l'ascension je
comprends mes collègues qui ont eu un
avis différent parce qu'encore une fois
je vois bien à quel point cette réforme
cristallise tant de tension aujourd'hui
je vois aussi à quel point le véhicule
qui a été employé pour la portée était
déloyale ce véhicule qui consistait à
utiliser un projet de financement de la
sécurité sociale au lieu d'assumer une
vraie réforme des retraites la mettre en
débat je vois aussi à quel point ce qui
aujourd'hui se plaignent d'un viol
démocratique sont les premiers à l'avoir
provoqué je pense à la France insoumise
qui a tout fait pour qu'il n'y ait pas
de débat qui a tout fait pour faire
obstruction à un vote et qui aujourd'hui
se plaint qu'elle ironise scandaleuse se
plaint qu'il n'y ait pas eu de vote mais
à qui le devons-nous qu'il n'y ait pas
eu de vote si ce n'est d'abord assez
parlementaires d'opposition qui ont été
indignes de leur mission en criant dans
l'Assemblée nationale au lieu de
répondre des arguments raisonnables et
donc il fallait engager un vrai débat le
gouvernement et le premier coupable de
cet échec parce qu'encore une fois ce
sujet il est majeur pour notre avenir
parmi bien d'autres la vérité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui
d'une certaine façon le gouvernement a
réussi à rendre profondément un
populaire et une réforme qui était
pourtant nécessaire et qu'il était
possible d'expliquer comme tel et même
la gauche avait réussi à faire une
réforme des retraites et on voit où nous
conduit encore une fois je le redis
cette politique de la confusion
permanente on voit où nous a conduit
cette majorité dans Emmanuel Macron
disait qu'elle devait être fière d'être
composée d'amateurs et bien je suis
désolé mais quand on dit à sa majorité
soyez fiers d'être des amateurs on
envoie le pays dans le mur et c'est ce
qui est en train de se produire
aujourd'hui et c'est ce qui est
révoltant et inquiétant pour l'avenir je
rembobine un tout petit peu parce qu'on
n'avait pas répondu à la question
d'Oriane tout à l'heure vous faites le
constat qu'il y a plus de majorité la
question c'était est-ce qu'il faut
dissoudre l'Assemblée nationale est-ce
qu'il faut prononcer sa dissolution oui
ou non et à quoi ça servirait
aujourd'hui
je ne crois pas qu'il faille dissoudre
l'Assemblée nationale je pense que moi
il me semble ça c'est pas ça qui peut
rétablir une majorité
tout le monde voit très bien que
cette équation politique ne tiendra pas
pendant 4 ans du coup on fait quoi je
n'imagine pas d'une certaine manière qui
est pas un moment dans le quinquennat ou
il faille revenir aux urnes mais la
question est-ce que c'est maintenant je
n'en suis pas sûr il y a une motion de
censure elle a été écartée soyons
raisonnable prenant au sérieux nos
institutions ce que je dis simplement
c'est que constatant la réalité de cette
situation
extrêmement ténue qui lui a permis de
survivre à une motion de censure je
crois qu'Elisabeth borne gagnerait
encore une fois à prendre un peu de
hauteur ça ça suffira pas ça calmera pas
forcément pas sur les quatre ans qui
viennent mais dans l'immédiat
aujourd'hui si on veut sortir de la
crise comment on appelle aujourd'hui le
président de la République prendra la
parole à la télévision demain demain à
13h qu'est-ce qu'il doit dire qu'est-ce
qui peut dire aux Français pour apaiser
la situation
j'espère qu'ils présentera ses excuses
d'abord parce qu'encore une fois je le
redis le grand responsable de cette
crise démocratique c'est lui la
politique du en même temps de la
confusion permanente la politique qui
nous a conduit aussi à perdre le sens
des réalités pourquoi les Français ne
mesurent-ils plus aujourd'hui la
nécessité d'une réforme des retraites
parce que nous avons tellement vécu dans
l'illusion de ce que le président
lui-même appelait l'argent magique nous
avons tellement vécu dans la facilité du
quoi qu'il en coûte nous avons tellement
vécu dans le dîner de réalité vous
m'avez entendu dire ça avec nos
collègues des républicains nous l'avons
dit pendant des années nous avons tiré
la sonnette d'alarme et aujourd'hui nous
constatons les dégâts du gouvernement
notamment Bruno Le Maire dit mais une
partie des républicains ont perdu leur
cohérence
continuelle dont nous vivons aujourd'hui
les conséquences directes c'est le
gouvernement auquel appartient Bruno Le
Maire et Bruno Luère lui-même qui a
endetté la France plus qu'aucun de ses
prédécesseurs sans aucune espèce de
sérieux sans aucune espèce d'exigence de
vérité et nous l'avons dit pendant des
années encore une fois et aujourd'hui
comment voudrais-on que les Français ne
comprennent pas qu'on leur demande de
faire des efforts quand on les a
habitués à cette fiction dangereuse
quand c'était la période électorale où
il s'agissait d'être réélu quand il
fallait seulement se maintenir au
pouvoir là pour le coup il y avait pas
de problème avec la dépense publique et
là pour le coup on a dépensé des
dizaines de milliards d'euros pour faire
en sorte que les Français vivent dans ce
déni de réalité qui a permis à Emmanuel
Macron d'être reconduit au pouvoir et
d'un seul coup maintenant qu'il est
réélu on vous explique qu'en fait il y
avait en réalité une difficulté à gérer
comment voulez-vous que les Français ne
soient pas dans l'incompréhension nous
ne avec les républicains nous avons
expliqué très clairement depuis le début
c'est notre ligne
ultra majoritaire que nous devons faire
avec le sérieux nécessaire pour que la
France retrouve confiance en son avenir
mais ce que je constate aujourd'hui
c'est que faute d'avoir tenu ce discours
cohérent et clair depuis le début le
gouvernement s'est privé de la majorité
politique nécessaire pour mener cette
réforme-là
vous avez quand même 19 députés
républicains qui ont voté pour la motion
de censure à l'encontre des consignes
qui avaient été données très clairement
par X série xoti président du parti et 3
et 3 qui ont voté celle du rassemblement
national
il y a encore une ligne claire dans
votre partie bien sûr ça n'enlève rien
au fait que le Bureau politique c'était
prononcé dans son écrasante majorité en
faveur de cette réforme
fait que le Sénat a fait un travail
extraordinaire pour faire en sorte que
la réforme puisse être corrigée dans
tous les travers qu'elle crée je pense
notamment à l'injustice sociale qu'elle
faisait peser sur les plus vulnérables
sur les femmes en particulier qui
aujourd'hui étaient les grandes
perdantes de cette réforme et le Sénat a
travaillé sur ce sujet et le groupe au
Sénat était très uni pour mener ce que
c'était pas la ligne d'érections
de censure ne soit pas votée là vous
avez 19 qui ont voté trois qui ont voté
celle du rassemble à ça est-ce qu'ils
ont encore leur place au sein des
républicains est-ce que vous souhaitez
qu'il soit exclus une grande majorité du
groupe à l'Assemblée nationale a refusé
de voter ses réformes émotions de de
censure aucun signataire des
républicains ne s'est associé à ces
motion de censure maintenant qu'on a dit
ça deux choses la première je ne crois
pas qu'on puisse effectivement regarder
la situation comme s'il ne s'était rien
passé pour nous non plus je le disais
tout à l'heure c'est une crise pour le
gouvernement c'est aussi une crise pour
les oppositions et pour les républicains
il est évidemment il faut évidemment
voir dans cet épisode le signe et là
encore je le dis depuis très longtemps
donc je n'ai pas l'impression de
découvrir la lune mais le signe qu'il y
a tout à reconstruire tout à refonder et
il faut d'abord reconstruire une
doctrine une vision une ligne de pensée
qui nous réunissent et c'est évidemment
dans cette direction que je m'étais
engagée dans la campagne interne pour la
présidence du parti c'est évidemment ce
travail là que nous avons aujourd'hui
autour d'erikiotti avec tous ceux qui
dirigent ce parti avec tous ceux qui le
font vivre nous avons tout à
reconstruire c'est une certitude je
crois qu'on va s'en
sortira pas par des exclusions on n'est
pas dans une situation telle qu'on
puisse se permettre de résoudre nos
désaccords en faisant sortir ce qui
témoignent une divergence je pense par
ailleurs que beaucoup de députés sont
aujourd'hui au contact de la réalité de
la crise sociale que traverse la forme
parce que la vraie catastrophe vous les
comprenez est-ce que vous comprenez
Aurélien Pradier moi je n'aurais pas
voté cette notion de censure je le redis
vous comprenez qu'il est voté mais je
comprends aujourd'hui je crois que c'est
très important de faire en sorte que
nous puissions répondre aux inquiétudes
d'une France qui a le sentiment d'être
directement victime du décrochage du
pays parce que le grand drame dans la
situation actuelle c'est que pendant
qu'on discute de la question de savoir
si on va travailler de 62 à 64 ans il se
passe des choses qui d'une certaine
manière sont d'une gravité bien plus
grande pour notre avenir la France
connaît un gigantesque des classements
services publics sont en train de
s'effondrer le déficit structurel du
pays rend son avenir incertain la dette
de la France est aujourd'hui une épée de
Damoclès qui pèse sur notre tête au
moment où les taux d'intérêt remontent
partout la situation géopolitique
globale fait que nous sommes aujourd'hui
dans un moment de tel instabilité que le
fait d'avoir à ce point perdu les
leviers pour maîtriser notre avenir
devrait être la source de notre première
inquiétude et c'est de cela qu'il faut
parler
il faut une ligne il faut qu'on ait une
ligne claire il faut qu'on ait une
parole crédible est-ce que c'est
possible avec des députés comme Aurélien
Pradier qui font entendre des voix si
dissonantes est-ce que c'est possible
d'avoir une ligne claire et du parent de
créer une parole crédible avec des gens
comme ça au sein de votre partie une
chose qui est certaine et je le dis très
librement c'est je crois que dans la
période que nous vivons aujourd'hui
aussi bien pour notre partie mais les
parties ne sont pas très importants ce
qui compte c'est notre pays aussi bien
pour notre partie que pour la vie
démocratique de notre pays personne n'a
le droit de jouer des aventures
personnelles contre la clarté du débat
public je crois que c'est fondamental
parce que nous sommes dans un moment
chacun doit avoir vraiment conscience de
sa responsabilité une fois que j'ai dit
cela je ne juge pas des collègues qui
sont parlementaires qui sont libres de
leur mandat et cela
ericki-t-il à lui-même rappelé avec
force nous croyons à la démocratie nous
ne croyons pas à la caserne et il est
fondamentale que tout le monde puisse
être entendu pour que nous
reconstruisions demain une famille
politique qui oui aura retrouvé un
discours clair et qui aura oui c'est
vrai rompu avec toute forme de démagogie
nous devons écouter ce que disent les
Français qui souffrent ça ne veut pas
dire pour autant que nous devons leur
mentir et quand j'entends le
rassemblement national qui nous explique
que s'il revient au pouvoir il abrochera
cette réforme je dis que le
rassemblement national ment comme toutes
les forces politiques qui ont fait ces
promesses là dans tous les autres pays
européens non cette réforme ne sera pas
abrogée pourquoi pour une raison très
simple c'est que nous avons besoin
d'équilibrer notre système de retraite
que nous avons besoin de faire en sorte
que la part des retraites ne devienne
pas
prépondérante dans le dans le produit
intérieur brut dans la richesse produite
par la France on ne peut pas s'acheter
pour longtemps une richesse qu'on ne
produit plus et quand le rassemblement
national prétend qu'il abrogera ça fait
forme je dis qu'en réalité il montre par
là qu'il cède à la facilité de la
démagogie et qu'il dévoile en réalité le
fait qu'il ne respecte pas les français
chez les républicains il va y avoir un
bureau politique aujourd'hui est-ce que
ça va changer quelque chose au sein du
parti est-ce qu'elle exoty a encore
l'autorité nécessaire qu'est-ce qu'il
faut changer au sein de votre partie et
bien je le redis et peut-être que nous
disions depuis très longtemps ce que
nous avons dit dans cette campagne
interne avec Bruno otailleuse que nous
avons partagé avec Éric Ciotti depuis
son élection ce matérialise aujourd'hui
il faut repartir du fond il faut
repartir des idées il faut reconstruire
une doctrine moi ce que j'observe c'est
que ce qui même dans nos rangs ce sont
hier opposés à cette réforme à travers
la notion de censure cela même
d'ailleurs qui en dehors de notre
famille politique ont déposé cette
motion de censure avait eux-mêmes il y a
quelques mois il y a quelques années dit
la nécessité d'augmenter l'âge de départ
à la retraite et donc il y a quelque
chose comme une espèce d'incohérence
généralisée qui je disais tout à l'heure
touche le gouvernement mais qui touche
aussi les oppositions et nous n'avons
pas le droit à nous de s'aider à la
facilité du en même temps nous n'avons
pas le droit de céder à cette confusion
qui abîme si profondément la vie
démocratique française sur la ligne
justement parce que certaines
personnalités et non des moindres je
pense à Rachida Dati prône un accord de
gouvernement entre les républicains
Emmanuel Macron qu'est-ce que vous dites
de ça est-ce que vous y êtes favorable
jamais de la vie en tous les cas pour ce
qui est de ma réponse et nous allons
effectivement parler aujourd'hui je vous
quitterai dans un instant pour aller au
comité stratégique du parking je crois
que aujourd'hui moins que jamais nous
devons refuser notre rôle notre
responsabilité c'est d'être des
opposants à Emmanuel Macron pour
proposer une alternative demain en
disant que je n'aurais pas voté la
motion censure je ne dis pas que je ne
veux pas faire tomber le gouvernement je
voudrais faire tomber le gouvernement
sur tout ce qui fait du mal aux Français
je voudrais faire tomber le gouvernement
sur sa politique migratoire totalement
irresponsable je de faire tomber le
gouvernement sur son incurie en matière
éducative je voudrais faire tomber le
gouvernement sur son incapacité à
redonner de la valeur au travail tout
cela est clé mais par pitié je crois
encore une fois ne confondons pas tout
lorsque le gouvernement est contraint
par des raisons extérieures et notamment
par ses engagements européens et
contraint de faire une réforme des
retraites que nous demandons depuis très
longtemps il me paraissait absurde
d'être incohérent au point de contredire
ce que nous avions demandé nous-mêmes
depuis si longtemps ça ne veut pas dire
que je ne suis pas un opposant je suis
je reste un opposant à la politique
d'Emmanuel Macron qui fait tant de mal à
la France une dernière chose peut-être
simplement pour dire que j'entends
certains aujourd'hui se plaindre que des
élus des républicains n'ont pas voté la
motion de censure mais je crois qu'on a
le devoir de respecter la cohérence
qu'ils ont montré votez une notion de
censure sur ce texte je comprends que
certains l'effet mais votre émotion de
censure sur ce texte c'était quand même
prendre le risque de se contredire à un
point tel que on fasse tomber un
gouvernement sur la mesure même que nous
demandions depuis des années
aujourd'hui certains élus qui ont reçu
un mandat des Français il y a quelques
mois il y a quelques années pour les
sénateurs ont décidé d'être cohérents et
cette cohérence là mérite d'être
respectée et personne n'a le droit
personne de chercher à intimider des
élus à faire pression sur eux allez
menacer de quelques violences que ce
soit je pense à tous nos collègues
sénateurs députés qui sont aujourd'hui
ciblés par des menaces d'une incroyable
gravité parfois par des gestes par des
actes d'une incroyable violence contre
leur permanence contre leur domicile
personnel je pense à Bruno retailleux
auquel je voudrais redire mon soutien à
qui la CGT a coupé le courant c'est la
démocratie et la coeur de la démocratie
c'est pas seulement de crier quand il y
a un 49-3 qui arrive le cœur de la
démocratie c'est de respecter le fait
que des élus qui défendent depuis
longtemps des convictions puissent avoir
le droit de les tenir avec cohérence au
moment où elles sont discutées pour
terminer sur les républicains il y en a
un chez vous qu'on a pas du tout entendu
ou très très peu c'est Laurent Wauquiez
alors il a pris sa retraite ou il attend
son heure leur invoqué ça ne vous aura
pas échappé il n'est pas parlementaire
il est président de région il fait son
travail de président en région et là
encore je crois chacun à droit de se
concentrer son candidat à la
présidentielle est-ce que dans un tel
moment pour le pays et pour les LR il
peut rester silencieux est-ce qu'il sait
pas de décrédibiliser non bien sûr que
non il fait les choix qu'il souhaite
pour pouvoir chercher les bons moments
pour s'exprimer on n'est pas encore ça
ne vous aura pas échappé dans un débat
présidentiel l'élection présidentielle
c'était il y a quelques mois seulement
je crois surtout le plus important c'est
si on pouvait cesser de parler des
tactiques personnelles des stratégies
individuelles le vrai sujet c'est la
France le vrai sujet c'est la crise que
nous traversons et ce sujet là c'est
celui qui devrait tous nous concerner
plus que la situation des individus qui
animent le débat politiquement vous
voyez les choses évoluées sur la
situation du pays notamment est-ce que
est-ce que on va vers vers des blocages
quelque chose qui dégénère des violences
ou est-ce que ça va est-ce que ça peut
encore s'apaiser naturellement ça posera
pas tout seul et encore une fois je le
redis il faudra que le gouvernement
montre il faudra que le Président de la
République montre qu'il a pris la mesure
du malaise démocratique pour un fromage
ce sera pas en recréant d’éniène gadget
le Conseil national de la refondation
qui a disparu à peine créée
parce que moi c'est pour ça que j'en
veux Emmanuel Macron la veille de
l'élection législative il était en train
d'expliquer pourquoi il allait créer une
institution parallèle qu'elle est
court-circuiter l'assemblée quand on
joue avec le feu on finit par récolter
ce qu'on est en train de vivre
aujourd'hui cette défiance qui s'exprime
dans le pays il faudra tirer les leçons
politiques de ce qui est en train de se
passer et moi c'est pour ça que j'espère
que le gouvernement va d'une certaine
manière être marqué par l'expérience de
cette motion de censure exclue à une si
faible majorité je crois qu'il faut
qu'ils avaient de borne en tire toutes
les conséquences pour la suite j'espère
aussi que les Françaises seront
comprendre la situation je crois que
dans les enquêtes d'opinion beaucoup de
Français disent qu'au fond ils savent
que cette réforme va être appliquée je
crois en tous les cas que ceux qui
disent qu'elles ne le sera pas ceux qui
disent qu'elle sera abrogée leur mentent
aujourd'hui et moi je le dis en venant
du Parlement européen ou beaucoup de nos
collègues au plan européen regarde avec
un peu de sidération ce qui se passe à
la France aujourd'hui nous sommes en
train de nous enliser dans un déficit
structurel dans une dette abyssale nous
ne produisons plus que nous consommons
nous n'avons jamais importé autant des
produits dont nous avons le plus besoin
il est temps de se remettre au travail
de réviser notre système de retraite ça
suppose aussi beaucoup de travail sur
beaucoup d'autres sujets qui vont
pouvoir mener de redonner la parole aux
Français sur ce sujet par voie
référendaire il y a un référendum
d'initiative partagé qui va être déposé
par par la gauche est-ce que vous pensez
que ça aurait du sens que ça peut
aboutir et que ça pourrait être un moyen
aussi de remettre tout sur la table et
de se redonner un peu de temps pour pour
repenser la question et vous savez moi
mon sentiment c'est que le sujet c'est
pas la réforme des retraites ou c'est
pas seulement la réforme des retraites
mon sentiment c'est que le malaise que
les Français vivent il vient de la
manière dont Emmanuel Macron gouverne
depuis des années donc un référendum
n'aurait pas d'utiliser donc le vrai
sujet c'est pas seulement cette question
on se tromperait si on pensait
d'ailleurs ceux qui pensent que la
réforme est adoptée et que maintenant
c'est fini qu'on va pouvoir tourner la
page rien faire de plus se trompe ce qui
pense que le sujet est seulement lié à
cette réforme des retraites à mon avis
se trompe aussi la question c'est de
retrouver un cap clair qui permet au
pays de de retrouver confiance en son
avenir et dans la vie démocratique merci
François-Xavier vous libérer puisque
vous devez retourner au sein de votre
partie merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité